guten Morgen grüß Gott
sehr geehrte Damen und Herren ich bin
oberstleitner Peer kugelweiß ich werde
sie heute durch die Veranstaltung
Pressegespräch zu 25 Jahre Soldatinnen
im Bundesheer begleiten das heutige
Pressegespräch wird führen
Verteidigungsministerin Claudia Danner
und Frau Offiziers Stellvertreterin
Karin pirschner in einer Militärpolizei
Gruppe in Innsbruck und ist Soldatin der
ersten Stunde sie ist eingerückt am 1
April
1998 in Strass in der Steiermark Frau
Bundesministerin bitte
Stellvertreterin sehr geehrte Damen und
Herren der Medien ja morgen 1 April vor
25 Jahren sind die ersten Frauen beim
Bundesheer als Soldatinnen eingerückt
das waren damals neun die sich für das
Bundesheer entschieden haben ja und eine
von ihnen die
heute hier neben mir Frau Offiziers
Stellvertreter Karin pirschner eine
militärpolizistin aus Tirol sie ist eine
der damals neuen eingerückten Frauen sie
ist bis heute im Beruf Soldatin
geblieben und es ist mir wirklich auch
ein persönliches Bedürfnis mich bei
Ihnen dafür zu bedanken und Ihnen dazu
zu gratulieren gleichzeitig hoffe ich
dass sie auch weiterhin als Vorbild bin
mir sicher dass sie das sein werden für
viele Frauen da draußen die das gleiche
Karriereziel wie sie anstreben an
unserer Seite stehen ja ein
Vierteljahrhundert ein
Vierteljahrhundert in einem leider noch
immer sehr männlichen Beruf zu sein das
ist alles andere als
selbstverständlich denn ganz offen für
Frauen und für Soldatinnen wahr und ist
es nicht immer leicht gerade zu Beginn
damals über 25 Jahren musste diese
Akzeptanz in den Reihen der Männer
durchaus erkämpft werden und so wie sie
heute als medienvertreterinnen und
Medienvertreter da sind war das vor 25
Jahren mindestens genauso viel ein
unglaublicher mehr noch Medien Rummel
damals weil eben eine Frau beim Herr
eine Rarität gewesen ist zur damaligen
Zeit jetzt ganz offen es hat sich ohne
Zweifel seitdem und wir haben im Vorfeld
darüber gesprochen sicher einiges
verändert weil wir Verbesserungen für
Frauen im Heer erreichen konnten und wir
diese immer mehr auch integriert haben
das beginnt beim Ausbau von
Kinderbetreuung das ist ein laufender
Prozess den wir weiterhin schrittweise
umsetzen müssen und ausbauen müssen
es gibt doch noch weitere
Fördermaßnahmen die wir ins Leben
gerufen haben dass großmentoring im
Bundesdienst also Mentoring für auch
weibliche Zivilbedienstete in dem Fall
insbesondere aber eben auch im Mentoring
für unsere Soldatinnen ja dann gibt es
jährlich ein großes AbsolventInnen
Treffen bei dem ich auch schon dabei
sein durfte da kommen die AbsolventInnen
der
jahresunteroffiziersakademie der
Landesverteidigungsakademie und der
Theresianischen Militärakademie einmal
im Jahr zusammen um sich auszutauschen
also eine Vernetzung sagt Initiative die
wirklich sehr wichtig ist die laufend
auch durchgeführt wird nicht zuletzt um
den Zusammenhalt auch unter den
weiblichen Bediensteten zu stärken und
zu fördern worauf setzen wir noch im
Resort wir setzen auf Frauen und
gleichbehandlungsbeauftragte in unseren
Dienststellen damit auch Anlaufstellen
da sind für die Frauen und zusätzlich
haben wir erst kürzlich am 23 März mit
unserer Werbekampagne Frauen beim her
gestartet das ist eine großmediale
Kampagne die von sozialen Medien bis hin
zu Plakatkampagnen reicht und die bis
Ende April zu sehen sein wird wo wir den
Scheinwerfer auf unsere Frauen im
österreichischen Bundesheer lenken
wollen
das alles aber sehr geehrte Damen und
Herren das ist nicht genug denn wir
haben unser Ziel noch lange nicht
erreicht in den letzten Jahren hat sich
der Frauenanteil beim österreichischen
Bundesheer erhöht stetiger erhöht so
hatten wir im Jahr 2013 einen
Frauenanteil von insgesamt 350
Soldatinnen ein Prozentsatz von 2,3
Prozent im Jahr 2018 waren es dann 572
Frauen beim Herr wir haben nur zehn
Jahre später mit stand märz haben wir
jetzt einen Frauenanteil 645 Soldatinnen
das entspricht einem Anteil von
4,3%, das ist niedrig das ist auch ganz
offen im europäischen Vergleich niedrig
und wir haben sehr vieles zu tun um
diesen Anteil zu erhöhen eine ganz
wichtige Maßnahme die wir nun ergriffen
haben ist der freiwillige
Grundwehrdienst für Frauen ja und die
Umsetzung dieses Projektes die startete
ab morgen
das ist eine Erweiterung eine Öffnung
für den Ausbildungsdienst für Mannschaft
und chargenfunktionen von Frauen wo wir
es endlich nach beinahe einem
Vierteljahrhundert geschafft haben dass
die Frauen einen niederschwelligen
Zugang zum Bundesheer ermöglicht
bekommen und das auch alle Funktionen
für Frauen gleichwertiger im Mannschaft
und im chargenfunktion geöffnet werden
weil jeder und jede die Möglichkeit hat
haben soll sein Land zu verteidigen die
gleichen Zugangschancen auch haben soll
beim Bundesheer um den wohl
einzigartigen Beruf der Soldaten des
soldates ausführen zu können ja morgen
startet dieses Projekt nicht nur
anlässlich von 25 Jahre Frauen beim
Bundesheer sondern auch im Hinblick auf
den Girlsday 2023 die am 27 April
stattfinden wird
was werden wir nun tun wir werden
insgesamt
142.000 Briefe an junge Frauen schicken
und zwar an die Geburtsjahrgänge 2003
bis 2006 das ist nicht so wie bei den
Grundwehrdienern ein stellungsbrief weil
er der Fokus bei den Frauen auf der
Freiwilligkeit liegt wir haben ja
gesetzlich nichts verändert sondern es
ist eine Einladung an die 142.000 Frauen
bei unserem Girlsday in den neuen
Bundesländern teilzunehmen und in diesem
Brief ist dann auch ein QR-Code drinnen
mit dem man auf unsere Website gelangt
die Bundeswehr dort
kommt.at so ist es richtig und dann
automatisch auch auf unsere
soldatinnenseite dort sind dann alle
Informationen zu finden über die
beruflichen Möglichkeiten für Frauen und
erstmalige geben die Öffentlichkeit auch
zu informieren über das neue
Ausbildungsmodell freiwilliger Grund
Wehrdienst wir werden natürlich diesen
Girls Day nutzen um persönlich die
Frauen und Mädchen anzusprechen auf
diese neue
Ausbildungsmöglichkeit der erste
stellungstermin dann der wird der Anfang
Mai also Dritter bis vierter mai wird
dieser erste stellungstermin für Frauen
vorgesehen sein und damit die ersten
Soldatinnen die sich für den
freiwilligen Grundwehrdienst entscheiden
die erwarten wir dann ab dem dritten
Quartal 2023 das heißt also ab Juli
August
wir werden dann dafür sorgen dass die
gemeinsame so zumindest zu zweit in eine
Kaserne bzw Einheit einrücken weil ich
glaube aber da weiß die Frau Offiziers
Stellvertreter viel mehr noch dazu dass
gerade ein Gemeinschaftsgefühl schon
auch sehr wichtig ist wie es ja in
Wahrheit die junge Männer täglich beim
Bundesheer erleben das war sehr
erfreulich ist wir haben bereits jetzt
schon ohne dass man sie im öffentlichen
ausgeschrieben haben 19 InteressentInnen
das ist der aktuelle Stand und ich
glaube dieses Ergebnis lässt uns sehr
positiv in die Zukunft bzw auf dieses
Projekt auch blicken als wir Ihnen dass
das erste Mal präsentiert haben haben
gesagt wir tun uns sehr schwer
einzuschätzen wie das Interesse sein
wird und wir haben damals gesagt das
kann von 0 bis 1000 gehen das stimmt uns
tatsächlich ja sehr positiv dass wir
hier die ersten InteressentInnen
Meldungen haben
was wird es einfach oder wie viel
niedriger wird die
Einstiegsschwelle werden bisher konnten
die Soldatinnen nur direkt in eine Kader
Laufbahn Offizier und offiziell mit
einer eigenen Eignungsprüfung beim
Heerespersonalamt in Wels einsteigen da
waren Fitness Tests notwendig eine
Leistung die zu erbringen ist und Sie
haben eigentlich das System Bundesheer
nicht kennenlernen können jetzt gibt es
die Möglichkeit so wieder sehr für jeden
Mann auch ist das Bundesheer
kennenzulernen innerhalb dieser dieses
ersten halben Jahres gleich wie die
männlichen Kollegen
das Bundes erkennen zu lernen dann sich
entscheiden zu können wollen wir damit
dabei bleiben wir geben damit den Frauen
die Chance mental und körperlich sich
besser auch vorbereiten zu können auf
den Beruf Soldaten gleiche Möglichkeiten
und Chancen damit auch wahrnehmen zu
können und ganz offen wir erhoffen uns
eben eine raschere Steigerung der Zahlen
von Frauen Wien Uniform ja zum Abschluss
bevor ich das Wort dann an die Frau
Offiziers Stellvertreterin weitergeben
darf oder vielleicht sie dann noch etwas
sagen dazwischen möchte ich nochmals
eines betonen dieses Konzept das wird
auf Freiwilligkeit beruhen es wird nach
einem Vierteljahrhundert nach 25 Jahren
keine Wehrpflicht für Frauen geben meine
persönliche Meinung dazu ist darüber
kann man dann diskutieren wenn es
Gleichberechtigung auf allen Ebenen und
in allen Bereichen gibt das was wir aber
tun müssen ist daran zu arbeiten dass
wir Frauen in und als Teil des
österreichischen Bundesheeres
integrieren den Anteil der Frauen so
weit steigern dass diese künftig nicht
mehr in der Minderheit sind und das
heißt nach den genannten Zahlen dass wir
ohne Zweifel ein harter und ein
steiniger Weg werden ich bin aber
überzeugt davon so lange wir Vorbilder
wie sie haben wird uns dieser Weg auch
gelingen vielen Dank und ich darf jetzt
anziehen übergeben bitte
danke sehr geehrte Frau
Verteidigungsminister sehr geehrte Damen
und Herren warum Bundesheer
also eigentlich wollte ich schon immer
Soldatin werden sagen 1998 hat sich dann
die Möglichkeit gegeben dass man zum
Bundesheer gehen kann wie hat es durch
die Medien erfahren dann habe ich
erfahren dass es auch die Militärpolizei
gibt dann habe ich gemeint das ist genau
das Richtige für mich einerseits der
Soldatenberuf und andererseits der
Polizeiberuf dass man das vereinbaren
können bin dann eben 98 mit den ersten
neuen Damen in Strass eingerückt und
habe dort meine erste Ausbildung
absolviert
dann weiter noch fünf Jahren Graz bin
ich dann nach Innsbruck zu Militär
Polizei weitergegangen für mich war die
Kombination als Militärpolizei die
richtige Wahl ich habe einige Einsätze
hinter mir
Kosovo Bosnien mehrmals
dann besondere Einsätze waren für mich
die flüchtlingskrise 2015 an der Grenze
ins Spielfeld das war schon sehr
ereignisreich ganz besonders die
Überwachung von Botschaften nach dem
schrecklichen Terroranschlag
am 2 November in Wien das war natürlich
auch eine besondere Herausforderung ich
bin seit 20 Jahren bei der
Militärpolizei in Innsbruck und für mich
war es immer klar dass ich die gleichen
Limits erreiche und den gleichen
einsatzleiste wie Männer bis vor einigen
Jahren war ich die einzige Frau bei der
Militärpolizei in Innsbruck inzwischen
sind wir fünf Damen
diese Entwicklung ist absolut positiv
und trägt natürlich auch zum
Betriebsklima bei das ist natürlich fein
weil man braucht doch schon immer wieder
mal eine Frau es gibt bestimmte
Frauenthemen wo man halt einfach besser
mit Frauen redet als dann doch mit
Männern
man merkt aber natürlich jetzt auch
dadurch dass ich schon
älter bin den generationswechseln wie
zum Beispiel diese Vorschläge mit
Work-Life-Balance es ist in gewissen
Bereichen wahrscheinlich auch möglich
bei uns weil es gibt ja auch schon
Telearbeiter oder Homeoffice aber als
Soldat oder einer Soldat in einer
Einsatzeinheit ist es nur schwer möglich
weil wenn der Befehl kommt du fährst
jetzt in Einsatz von Forst da kannst
jetzt sagen kann jetzt nicht gell
in der letzten 25 Jahren hat sich auch
für uns Soldaten einiges zum Positiven
verändert ich glaube das mit dem neuen
Konzept der freiwillige Grundwehrdienst
für Frauen dass ich da mehr Frauen
melden werden weil das Auswahlverfahren
voll Weg das ist ein bestimmtes würde
gewesen für manche die vielleicht die
körperliche Leistungsfähigkeit noch
nicht so erbracht haben haben aber sich
da nicht getraut sich beim Bundesheer zu
bewerben jetzt haben Sie die Möglichkeit
dass sie gehen können wie ein Mann
gleiche Voraussetzungen wie ein Mann
sich das in diesen sechs Monaten
anzuschauen und dann zu entscheiden ja
ich bleibe oder ich gehe
mein Tipp für Frauen die Möglichkeiten
sind da aber man muss es aber auch
wollen also da sein ist normal
für mich war es eine Berufung und so
sollte es auch für die zukünftigen
Soldaten oder Soldatinnen sein und ich
würde mich auch heute weiterhin immer
für diesen Beruf entscheiden weil ich
bin glücklich und zufrieden in meinem
Beruf danke
danke sehr es besteht nun die
Möglichkeit Fragen zu stellen bitte
stellen Sie die Fragen ins Mikrofon
ja ORF Radio Frau Ministerin sie sagen
die Zahlen sind schwer einzuschätzen zum
freiwilligen Grundwehrdienst was wäre
denn das höchstmögliche wo sie sagen das
können wir aufnehmen und das können wir
auch gut begleiten und Frau Pirchner was
hat sich denn in den letzten 25 Jahren
verändert her sie haben die Innensicht
und vielleicht auch was müssen denn
junge Frauen wie sich das überlegen was
müssen die mitbringen ihrer Meinung nach
also wenn ich beginnen darf für jede
einzelne werden wir jede einzelne werden
wir mit offenen Armen empfangen und auch
einen Platz haben das heißt eine Grenze
nach oben die gibt es nicht die
Einschätzung wie groß das Interesse ist
wenn man etwas neu beginnt die ist heute
ein bisschen schwierig aber wie gesagt
da stand jetzt ohne dass wir sozusagen
die Werbemaßnahmen noch ergriffen haben
dass sie schon 19 InteressentInnen
gemeldet haben die lässt mich durchaus
hoffen also jede einzelne wird das
österreichische Bundesheer
mitbringen so wir mal wie schon vorher
erwähnt habe man muss es schon wollen
also Soldaten
ich bin Krankenschwester oder sonst
irgendeine berufsspartei damit
identifizieren was es heißt soll da zu
sein
mitbringen muss sie natürlich schon ein
bisschen körperliche Voraussetzungen und
wie gesagt auch die geistige
Voraussetzung es ist einfach so weißt du
doch ein bisschen noch einmal
außergewöhnlicher Beruf ist geändert hat
die Männer waren natürlich um Gottes
Willen Frau beim Bundeswehr das kann
nicht funktionieren wir haben bewiesen
es kann funktionieren und jetzt ist es
eigentlich ein normales Bild schon dass
Frauen in der Kaserne sein und das ist
nicht mehr außergewöhnliches
eine Frage an die Frau Minister von den
servus Nachrichten sie haben jetzt immer
die Freiwilligkeit betont aber wie
schaut sie mit der Bezahlung aus dem
gibt es eine Garantie dass auch die
Frauen dann im Grundwehrdienst gleich
viel verdienen wie die Männer und da
kein Unterschied gemacht wird
es war ja sogar die Kritik da dass sie
bei diesem Modell des freiwilligen
grundwertdienstes mehr bekommen als die
Männer die Rekruten das stimmt ja so
nicht es ist ein Betrag von monatlich
momentan 1251 Komma ein paar sind Euro
weil wir gesetzlich ja nichts verändert
haben das ist der Ausbildungsdienst für
Frauen der eben über ein Jahr geht und
auch jeder Rekruten nach diesem halben
Jahr das
Grundwehrdienstes die Entscheidung
trifft der freiwillig geben zu
verlängern kriegt dasselbe bezahlt daher
ich glaube das ist etwas das ist ja im
öffentlichen Dienst gibt dem gleiche
Bezahlung für gleiche Leist ung aber
leider wenn man sich die aktuellen
Zahlen noch anschaut ist das in der
Wirtschaft ja nach wie vor noch nicht so
und vielleicht auch an diese Stelle zu
betonen nicht nur die gleiche Bezahlung
sondern eben auch die gleichen
Aufstiegsmöglichkeiten die wir damit
eben für Frauen bitten wollen
sie haben gesagt Freiwilligkeit weil er
wir wollen erst dann sozusagen eine
Wehrpflicht für Frauen wenn es auch in
allen Bereichen in der Gesellschaft so
weit kommt dass eine Gleichstellung da
ist jetzt wird mich die interessieren
die Sprache also das Gendern in dem Sinn
ja sozusagen sprechen wir jetzt nur von
Soldaten Soldatinnen sie sprechen die
meiste Zeit von Soldat als Frau würde
mir jetzt nicht angesprochen fühlen wenn
es nicht von Soldaten also mit Sprache
ja auch sozusagen die das Bewusstsein
schafft gibt's da auch innerhalb des
Bundesheers schon irgendwie Vorgaben zu
sagen dass man auch in der Sprache etwas
verändern möchte
ich glaube Sprache ist da etwas sehr
Wichtiges dass das schafft das schafft
er schon auch ein Bild aber noch viel
mehr schafft das Bild das Bild dass ich
verändert hat dass eben die Soldatin
keine Exotin mehr ist was die Frage der
Dienste gerade anbelangt die sie
wahrscheinlicher ansprechen dann höre
ich von unseren Soldatinnen immer wieder
sehr bringen die gleiche Leistung und
daher wollen sie auch den gleichen
Dienstgrad haben ich glaube auch das ist
eine Frage die wir
immer wieder diskutieren auch das
passiert aber insbesondere eben bei den
angesprochenen auch Vernetzungstreffen
das ist nicht der erste Punkt der von
unseren Soldatinnen angesprochen wird
als einer der zu verändern der zu
verändern ist was ich generell mit der
Frage des
grundwehrdienste und eben nicht
freiwillig die Frauen gemeint habe wir
dürfen die Augen nicht davor
verschließen dass es wenn man vielleicht
dann auch noch alleinerziehend ist dies
alles zu bewältigen daher bin ich
überzeugt davon dass eine Verpflichtung
zu jetzigen Zeitpunkt nicht der richtige
Schritt ist sondern eben die
einstiegsschwellen zu senken und damit
sozusagen mit diesen Modellen auch
wirklich die die die Frauen zu locken
uns zu zeigen auch als durchaus
attraktiver Dienstgeber und wenn ich die
letzten Worte von der Offiziers
Stellvertreterin so höre dann tut das
schon gut dann sind wir da schon ein
Stück weiter gekommen wenn man nach
dieser Zeit noch sagen kann das ist ein
Beruf der den ich ja kein Beruf nur
sondern eben eine eine Berufung
es denn aus auch aus ihrer Erfahrung
wichtig dass mehr Frauen im Meer sind
und seitens hätten Sie damals den
freiwilligen grundverdienst gemacht wenn
sie schon gegeben hätte und warum wäre
das besser gewesen als so wie sie damals
eingerückt sind in der Kader Laufbahn
dass es besser gewesen ist ich bin so
eingerückt wie es damals im vorgesehen
war das Auswahlverfahren war für mich
kein Problem
weil das Glück hat immer Sportlerin
gewesen zu sein und ich wollte das also
ich muss sagen ich wollte das ist meine
persönliche Meinung für mich war ich
wollte das so haben und das war auch für
mich damals gut so wie gesagt ich finde
es gut dass es jetzt anders ist dadurch
bin immer sicher dass mehr Frauen zum
Bundesagent
und ja
ich es trägt einfach zur Kameradschaft
dabei also ich habe das gemerkt wenn
mehr Frauen sind es ist ein es herrscht
dann schon ein bisschen anderer
Umgangston das muss man sagen es trägt
zu Kameradschaft bei und wenn man jetzt
eher mit den zu meiner jüngeren
Kameraden redet das ist einfach
willkommen
Männer und Frauen zusammenarbeiten
und vielleicht strengen sie die Männer
dann ein bisschen mehr an wenn Sie sehen
dass die Frauen gut sind
[Gelächter]
von der APA sie haben am Anfang viel
hohen Zahlen gesprochen gibt es
längerfristig vielleicht einen
Prozentsatz an Frauen im Herden Sie sich
wünschen würden
wünschenswert Grenze nach oben gibt es
überhaupt keine aber wir haben ja einen
einen Frauenförderplan an dem wir seit
der Erlassung dessen schon arbeiten und
da ist natürlich einer der Prozentsätze
der auch international oder im
europaweiten Vergleich einer ist die man
anpeilt das sind die 15 Prozent es sind
an dieser Stelle auch nicht verhält dass
ich auch andere europäische Armeen nicht
ganz leicht tun damit das muss man ganz
offen fragen muss man ganz offen sagen
eine Grenze nach oben gibt es nicht wie
gesagt diese Prozentsatz der 15% wäre
einer den wir eben auch im
Frauenförderplan so vorgesehen haben
dann sind wir am Ende des Pressegespräch
so 25 Jahre Soldatinnen im Bundesheer
gekommen es besteht nun die Möglichkeit
bilateral Interview zu führen danke sehr
danke Ihnen vielmals für Interesse